les chéris la réponse donc de benjamin
biolay vous avez dit qu'il avait touché
500 mille euros pour la nouvelle star
est ce que cette info est vraie ce que
cette info est fausse est-ce que vos
autodata vous avez déjà des infos s qui
livrait ses maximes guinée où benjamin
biolay non moi un autre avis
complètement différent mais ça canarde
mais dire les salaires des gens trouvent
ça complètement mais affreux en fait
c'est le jeu médiatique imagine ça se
passera entre nous là bas je vais le
donner mes bases du talion notre chagrin
tu verras qu'on serait on tue ton pays
bas et on accepte de venir donc c'est
pour informer le public et puis on les
surnomme l arrivée chez rim
avant toute chose il s'agissait d'une
information tpm père coupait par deux
journalistes de la rédaction la saison
dernière d'accord et si les chiffres us
si bien benjamin biolay déclare que ces
chiffres sont en dehors des réalités
on peut entendre ce qu'il dit il arrive
que nous fassions des avoirs et si
c'était le cas ma on ne sommes ensemble
désolé ça peut arriver
voilà simplement c'est pas ma faute il
met notre jeholet moi je défends
complètement maxime guény away benjamin
biolay si c'est faux il a qu'a donné la
somme
il critique sur une somme à celui dit
ceux de sèvres à 500 mille euros c'est
temps et pourquoi mairie va partir il
révèle en vaut deux journées de garde
est énorme dit n'importe quoi
nous tailler toi le laisser l'eau répond
c'est vrai alors ton salaire j'ai levé
gilles et on avait fait une fois pour
moi les gens de magazines appels et des
balles arrêtées
votre salon on va donner tel salaire si
vous voulez donner le vôtre dit le sinon
nous on dit ça donc voila voila les
méthodes de journalisme c'est pas du
journaliste constatant l'impasse et eu à
fermer quelque chose en espérant que
l'accusé ni l'art de toi tu es là tu
arrêtes de chrétiens ont fait pas
d'abord à 500 mille euros c'est sûr
maxime mais nous avons eu envie d'avoir
la voie à la vraie réponse bâton et j'ai
envie d'avoir la vraie réponse est ce
que vous dites on s'emballe ex-mari
seule visée on s'en bat l'oeil
voilà leur sang sans balech mais secundo
pour avoir fait une interview en sur ce
sujet benjamin répondait vous répondre
et d'ailleurs qui pouvait vous envoyer
son sont le montant qu'ils touchaient en
privé et en perso mais pas l'annoncer à
la télé mais il serait d'apaiser les
choses voilà on peut faire
c'est vrai ça veut dire ça peut arriver
on va dire que salon la salle r dopage
ama
quand mais je pense que ça va lui faire
plaisir d'accord on s'emballe avec vous
emballe etc et vous vous vous le
connaissez bien en plus moi j'ai
travaillé deux fois avec lui deux fois
j'ai demandé de faire de la musique pour
un court métrage ou n'étaient pas payés
et pour une pièce de théâtre
ma pièce de théâtre où ils n'étaient pas
payés et laâyoune et il a dit oui
absence aucun problème alors nous
devrions prendre de la graine fait des
choses mais ça allait venir ici qu'un
petit peu comme ça pour le kiff bas vous
devriez aussi oui et elle leur parle
d'or mais entend en tant que journaliste
que tu viens de dire gilles c'est
irrecevable
oui ça veut dire que n'importe qui peut
lâcher une somme énorme ai dit vous êtes
condamné vous est cité à comparaître le
nom populaire mais un système
dictatorial 10 mai le tribunal populaire
obama sera sur twitter il touche un
salaire de tous les chroniqueurs c'est
ce que je vois